Dans chaque groupe de filles, il y a un gai luron,
celle vers qui on se tourne pour pleurer,
celle qui vous dit d'écraser quand la journée a été mauvaise.
C'était pareil dans ce groupe.
Sauf qu'il s'agit d'une communauté de femmes révolutionnaires,
mises ensemble,
qui sont devenues une équipe, puis amies, et enfin, une famille,
dans l'endroit le plus improbable :
le champ de bataille des Opérations Spéciales.
C'était un groupe dont l'amitié et les valeurs ont été cimentées
pas uniquement par leur expérience ou leurs faits de guerre,
mais par le fait qu'elles étaient là,
à une époque où on interdisait aux femmes, du moins officiellement,
d'aller au front.
Les Etats-Unis ne savaient même pas qu'elles existaient.
L'histoire commence quand des chefs des Opérations Spéciales,
des hommes parmi les plus expérimentés de l'Armée,
ont dit : « Nous avons besoin de femmes pour mener cette guerre.
Les Etats-Unis ne peuvent pas tuer jusqu'à la fin de la guerre.
Il faut plus d'intelligence, il faut mieux comprendre. »
Comme vous le savez tous,
quand on veut comprendre ce qui se passe dans une communauté ou dans une maison,
il faut parler aux femmes.
Que ce soit au Sud de l'Afghanistan,
ou en Californie du Sud.
Mais ici, les hommes ne pouvaient pas parler aux femmes.
Car dans la société conservative et traditionnelle qu'est l'Afghanistan,
ça serait une injure grave.
On avait besoin de femmes soldats sur place.
A ce moment de la guerre, ça signifiait que les femmes engagées
pour servir leur pays avec les Rangers et les Navy SEALs,
allaient vivre dans les mêmes conditions de combats
vécues par moins de 5% des militaires américains.
Moins de 5%.
Le recrutement a eu lieu.
« Femmes soldats: Faites partie de l'histoire.
Rejoignez les Opérations Spéciales sur le front en Afghanistan. »
On est en 2011.
Et de l'Alabama à l'Alaska,
un groupes de femmes qui avaient toujours voulu réaliser quelque chose qui a du sens
aux côtés de la crème de la crème,
et faire la différence pour leur pays,
a répondu à cet enrôlement.
Il ne s'agissait pas de politique, mais de servir leur pays.
Les femmes qui se sont réunies en Caroline du Nord
pour gagner leur place au sein de ces équipes,
qui allaient les envoyer sur le front des Opérations Spéciales,
ont forgé très vite une communauté
qu'elles n'avaient jamais vue auparavant.
Une communauté de femmes athlétiques et impitoyables,
qui partageaient le même objectif : faire la différence.
Elles n'ont pas dû s'excuser pour ce qu'elles sont,
au contraire, elles pouvaient le revendiquer.
Là-bas, elles ont découvert soudainement
qu'il y avait beaucoup de femmes comme elles.
Une d'entre elles a dit :
«C'est le moment où on a réalisé
qu'il y avait plus d'une girafe dans le zoo. »
Au sein de cette équipe remarquable, il y a Cassie,
une jeune femme qui a réussi l'exploit d'être à la fois
cadette de l'Ecole d'Officer (ROTC), membre d'une sororité,
et licenciée en étude des genres.
Il y a Tristan, une étoile montante de West Point,
qui ne portait jamais de chaussettes pour courir ou marcher.
L'odeur de ses chaussures le prouvaient.
(Rires)
Il y a Amber, une femme au look de Heidi,
qui a toujours voulu être dans l'infanterie.
Quand elle a su que les femmes en étaient exclues,
elle a décidé d'entrer dans les Renseignements.
Elle est partie en Bosnie,
et a aussi aidé le FBI à démanteler des cartels de drogue en Pennsylvanie.
Il y a Kate, qui a joué au foot américain
pendant tout son lycée.
Elle a voulu arrêter après un an,
et rejoindre le chœur de l'école.
Mais on lui a dit que le foot était pour les hommes,
elle a décidé de rester
pour ouvrir la voie aux autres filles.
La biologie a déterminé leur destin en partie.
Cassie l'a très bien expliqué :
« Ce qui est noble est hors de portée des filles. »
Maintenant, elles avaient la chance de servir aux côtés de l'élite,
dans une mission prioritaire pour leur pays,
non pas en dépit de leur féminité,
mais grâce à elle.
Sur bien des aspects, c'était une équipe de femmes comme beaucoup d'autres.
Elles se maquillaient.
Des liens très forts se sont créés aux toilettes, en parlant mascara.
Elles portaient aussi des armures.
Elles ajustaient 23 kilos de barda sur leur dos,
montaient en hélicoptère remplir une mission,
en revenait et regardait à la télé « Mes meilleures amies. »
(Rires)
Elles portaient des combinaisons gainantes Spanx.
Elles ont vite découvert
que les uniformes conçus pour les hommes
étaient larges là où ils auraient dû être étroits, et vice-versa.
Lane, un vétéran de la guerre en Irak, sur ma gauche,
a décidé de faire du shopping sur Amazon,
pour acheter une gaine Spanx.
Ainsi, son pantalon tient mieux quand elle est en mission la nuit.
Ces femmes se retrouvaient en vidéo-conférence,
au départ de leurs bases respectives en Afghanistan.
Elles discutaient de leur ressenti
d'être une des seules femmes à faire ce métier.
Elles plaisantaient.
Elles parlaient de ce qui allait bien, moins bien,
de ce qu'elles avaient appris, des techniques à améliorer.
Elles parlaient aussi de moments légers, de ce que signifie être une femme,
au front avec les Opérations Spéciales,
le « Shewee », par exemple,
un instrument qui leur permet d'uriner comme les hommes,
même si sa précision, avec 40%, laisse à désirer.
(Rires)
Ces femmes accumulent les « et ».
Elles sont la preuve qu'on peut être impitoyable et féminine,
qu'on peut porter du mascara et une armure,
qu'on peut aimer le CrossFit et le point de croix,
qu'on peut adorer sauter en hélico et aimer faire de la pâtisserie.
Les femmes vivent dans le « et » à chaque instant de la journée.
Elles ont emporté cette dualité dans leur mission aussi.
Sur le champ de bataille, où la vie ne tient à rien,
elles n'ont jamais oublié
que leur féminité les a amenées sur le front,
mais que c'est comme soldat qu'elles ont leur raison d'être.
Une nuit que Amber était en mission,
elle a appris en parlant aux femmes de la maison
qu'il y avait un tireur camouflé
qui attendait que les forces afghanes et américaines entrent dans la maison.
Une autre nuit, Tristan a découvert
qu'il y avait des éléments d'explosifs
tout autours de la maison où elles se tenaient,
et qu'il y avait des explosifs de cette maison,
à l'endroit de leur mission cette nuit-là.
Une autre nuit, un membre de l'équipe a démontré sa perspicacité
aux membres des SEALs, tous sceptiques,
en découvrant les informations qu'ils recherchaient
camouflées dans un lange.
Isabelle, une autre membre de l'équipe,
a découvert ce que son unité recherchait.
Elle a reçu la décoration Impact des Rangers,
qui ont affirmé que sans elle,
tout ce qu'ils recherchaient cette nuit-là
leur aurait échappé.
Chacune des nombreuses nuits,
elles sont parties en mission, prouver leur valeur,
au nom de toutes celles qui leur succéderont,
et au nom des hommes avec lesquels elles ont combattu.
On dit souvent que dans l'ombre d'un grand homme,
il y a une femme extraordinaire.
Dans ce cas-ci,
à côté des femmes, il y avait des hommes qui voulaient qu'elles réussissent.
Le Ranger qui les a entrainées a participé à 12 déploiements.
Mais quand on lui a dit qu'il allait entraîner des femmes,
il ne savait pas à quoi s'attendre.
Mais après 8 jours avec ces femmes, durant l'été 2011,
il a dit à un collègue Ranger : « On vient de vivre un moment historique.
Elles risquent de devenir nos 'Tuskegee Airmen' ».
(Applaudissements)
Elles ont surnommé l'une d'elles
« la meilleure d'entre nous ».
C'est une petite blonde dynamique,
qui mesure à peine 1 m 60.
Elle a ce côté sauvage de Martha Stewart,
mieux connue sous le nom de G.I. Jane.
Elle adorait préparer les repas pour son mari,
un officier de réserve de Kent State,
qui la poussait à donner le meilleur d'elle-même,
à avoir confiance en elle,
et à tester toutes ses limites.
Elle adorait courir des kilomètres avec son barda de 23 kilos.
Elle adorait être un soldat.
Elle avait un four à pain dans son bureau, à Kandahar.
Elle cuisait du pain au raisin, et allait à la salle d'entraînement
pour faire 25 à 30 tractions.
C'est le genre de personnes que vous appelez
si vous avec besoin d'un paire de bottes ou un repas fait maison.
Elle ne vous parlait jamais, vraiment jamais,
de ses performances.
Elle s'exprimait à travers ses actions.
Elle est réputée pour choisir le bon mais plus difficile chemin.
Elle est aussi réputée pour grimper une corde de 5 mètres,
à la force des bras,
et ensuite présenter ses excuses,
parce qu'elle sait qu'elle doit utiliser aussi ses jambes,
ainsi que les Rangers le lui ont enseigné.
(Rires)
Certains de nos héros rentrent à la maison et peuvent raconter leur histoire.
Mais pas tous.
Le 22 octobre 2011,
le lieutenant Ashley White a été tuée, avec deux Rangers,
Christopher Horns
et Kristoffer Domeij.
Sa mort a mis sous le feu des projecteurs
un programme prévu pour rester dans l'ombre.
A ce moment-là,
les femmes étaient toujours interdites des zones de combat.
A ses funérailles,
le chef des Opérations Spéciales a rendu un témoignage public
du courage d'Ashley White,
et de toutes ses consœurs de l'équipe.
Il a dit : «Ne vous méprenez pas. Ces femmes sont des guerrières.
Elles ont écrit un nouveau chapitre sur la valeur des femmes
au sein de l'Armée américaine.»
La maman d'Ashley est éducatrice et conduit un bus scolaire.
Elle fait de la pâtisserie aussi.
Elle garde peu de souvenir de ces journées bouleversantes,
ou la fierté se diluait dans la peine,
dans sa peine insurmontable.
Mais elle se souvient d'un seul moment.
Une inconnue s'est approchée d'elle avec sa petite fille
et lui a dit : « Madame White,
je suis venue avec ma fille aujourd'hui
parce que je voulais lui montrer à quoi ressemble un héros.
Je voulais qu'elle comprenne que les héros sont parfois des femmes. »
Le temps est venu de célébrer toutes les héroïnes de l'ombre,
qui ont eu les tripes, le cœur et la volonté
de persévérer et de tester leurs limites.
Cette bande improbable de sœurs, unies pour la vie et dans la mort,
fait partie de l'histoire.
Car elles ont tracé la voie pour toutes celles qui les ont suivies,
tout comme elles se sont appuyées sur celles qui les ont précédées.
Ces femmes ont prouvé que les guerriers ont des formes et des tailles variés.
Les femmes sont aussi des héros.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)